uh let's go next to
where do we want to go next because
there's just such a plethora
of people wanting to get on why don't we
go to
um let's go to zayler from rhode island
zayler from rhode island you're on the
air hello david how are you today
i'm doing well thank you i must say i
love discord for some reason on the
phone line i would uh you would say
something and i would hear it 10 seconds
later so this is much nicer
that's beautiful all right so if we win
both the senate seats in georgia which i
hope we do with
awesome uh warnock yes how likely is it
that
there might be a democrat defector in
the senate that might cause a problem
so i know that for instance joe manchin
he's still
in the senate in west virginia is it
that
despite us getting 50 seats that that's
going to be uh
an issue for us i i agree i mean listen
when you think about something like you
know uh the public option that joe biden
wants
um it's not even clear every democrat
supports that i don't know if joe
manchin
supports that so the 50 50 with kamala
as the tiebreaker
is the starting point but you are going
to potentially have a lot of trouble
actually whipping all the votes that
that you would need to even get to the
50
so i completely agree with you now on
the other side of that there may be some
reason
slightly marginally more reasonable
republicans that would be willing to
come over as well
but i think you're completely right that
just getting to 50 50 with kamala as the
theoretical tie-breaking vote it doesn't
really get big legislation
legislation done it's still going to be
a big fight
yeah and obviously the moderate dems are
slaves to their
districts whoever elected them are there
even any republicans who
could be persuaded over for legislation
like that like that could defect from
their side
it depends on the issue completely
you're not going to get susan collins to
come over and say medicare for all right
but there there are certainly
ways in which you know there are
probably funding related things
or or you know priorities or whatever
where joe manchin because of his west
virginia electorate might not be with
the democrats
but susan collins because of the main
electorate
might be with the democrats so there are
definitely examples but you're not going
to pass
like tax reform biden's tax reform
proposal
you're not gonna get that because of
republicans with joe manchin
not participating that's not gonna
happen you're gonna need every democrat
for that
and how how much of a problem of
thornton in the side do you think the
filibuster might be
if we do get um very close margins on
legislation i think it will be a problem
i i think that if
if democrats do get 50 50
and biden is in a position to pass some
major legislation i do think the issue
of the filibuster will come up but
on what issue i don't yet know
and what do you think so far with the
supreme court that
we have now yeah and even previous to
the death of rgb or rbg rather
rbg right um the
legislation i mean the cases rather that
pass through the supreme court
i remember that there was the victory
with the
anti-discrimination for tribes trans
people if i remember correctly but that
happened not too long ago
do you see any uh cases or any
important decisions being made by the
supreme court that could be negative
given
uh the now uh very cemented conservative
majority
on the court uh absolutely i wouldn't be
able to say what we first have to see
what comes before the court but i i'm
very worried about uh
about the supreme court for sure listen
i've got a run sailor but i appreciate
the call
i love that so many people called in i'm
not able to take more calls
today but we will take more calls soon
and we will take a quick break and be
back with much more